[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my breakdown of the joker
movie ending
hopefully you've had a chance to see the
movie we're doing a giveaway for tickets
all you have to do to enter is just be a
subscriber
and leave your favorite joker moment on
the video please do use spoiler tags at
least till we get through the weekend
just to give everyone a chance to see
the movie
and if you have not seen it just blanket
spoiler warning because we will be
talking about everything that happens at
the end of the movie
most of the questions that i've seen you
guys commenting on my joker movie review
video it's just a question
of what is real and what is fake because
the joker is an unreliable narrator
as is his mother or at least we're led
to believe that she's an unreliable
narrator because there are a lot of
questions about that picture that she
carried around of her
signed by thomas wayne with a special
message so i've seen some fantastic
theories that you guys have had about
this
but really when we talk about the ending
that starts when he learns that he's
secretly been adopted while he's at
arkham asylum getting his files on his
mother
she had previously worked for the waynes
about 30 years ago and believed that she
had a relationship with thomas wayne at
least that's what she thinks
she keeps writing him letters eventually
arthur reads one of the letters and in
it
she tells thomas wayne that arthur is
his son
so arthur believes that he's the son of
thomas wayne but because a lot of the
events
in arthur's life he made up and then you
later learned things did not happen the
way that he thought that they happened
you're led to believe that that might be
fake he's not really the son of thomas
wayne and his mother was lying the whole
time because as thomas
wayne says she was institutionalized
there are even adoption papers for
arthur inside her file
we learned that the affliction that
causes him to laugh the reason behind
his crazy laugh
is because of the head trauma he
received when he was abused as a child
so his world starts to unravel he goes
suffocates his mother to death
then begins to just completely fly off
the chain starts painting himself up in
joker makeup
his former friend seemingly that sold
him the gun earlier in the film and then
ratted him out comes to visit him
because of the police
to make sure that he doesn't tell them
the wrong thing that will get him in
trouble
he winds up killing him before he goes
on murray franklin's tv show
in full joker makeup lets his smaller
friend go
you were the only one that was nice to
me so at this point you're starting to
question
what's real and what's fake because he
climbs into a refrigerator and a lot of
people
think that he actually died in the
refrigerator and the rest of the movie
is imagined
but the reason why i don't think that's
the case is because too much of the
movie
happens in that last 15 minutes for him
to have all experienced it within his
mind
while he was dying inside a refrigerator
so i think the takeaway from the
refrigerator is that it's him just
slowly
transforming metaphorically into the
joker character like he goes into a
chrysalis
inside the refrigerator then he merges
more the joker than he's ever been
before
the basketball game music swells up as
he rolls out of his apartment in full
joker costume and makeup
dancing down the stairs in the montage
that they put in all the trailers
but the cops that have been after him
the whole movie chase him into the
subway
he uses the clown rise up movement to
stop them inadvertently starts a riot in
the subway
later claims that he has nothing to do
with that movement and thomas wayne
himself is also partially responsible
for all these people wearing clown masks
that i'll explain in a second
you get the scene of him waiting in the
green room on the murray franklin show
that we've seen in all the trailers
where he talks to murray and his
assistant producer played by
mark maron one thing when you introduce
me can you introduce me as
joker sure thing bud sounds great him
being on the tv show is meant to be a
mirror of the dream sequence from
earlier in the film it's exactly how i
imagined it he says so he dances on it's
this wonderful introduction he's
charming everyone he kisses the old lady
doctor then sits down
and gives his big speech about how
society is just as bad as
villains how the rich doesn't care about
the poor there's this big class war
going on during the movie
no one cares about him because rich man
thomas wayne isn't talking about him on
live tv
the way he was talking about the three
douchebags that he killed earlier on the
subway
he freely admits to killing them and
it's almost like he's taking this weight
off of his shoulders like i'm tired of
pretending
that it's not funny it's funny comedy is
subjective
he claims that he didn't kill them to
start a movement he's not political
i'm not trying to start any kind of
thing i killed them because they were
terrible
then he calls out murray franklin for
being just as terrible and he has his
iconic line what do you get when you
cross a mentally deranged loner with a
society that treats him like crap
you get what you freaking deserve then
kills robert de niro's character murray
franklin on live tv
remember this is taking place in the
late 70s early 80s so there was no time
delay built into the broadcast system
everybody that was watching murray
franklin saw that happen
the clown movement that's happening in
the streets during the last 15 minutes
of the movie just boils over
everyone just riding everywhere in the
streets their fires cars turned over
the joker throws all this gasoline on
that fire with his presentation he looks
into the camera and starts speaking
just as the station cuts him off then
things get really subjective this is
where you're really getting inside his
head as he's being driven away in the
back of a cop car you're meant to
believe that he was arrested by the
police
and he maybe gave himself up he's
smiling as they're driving through all
the riots but then a couple of his
admirers wearing clown masks crash an
ambulance into the cop car that has him
freeing him then he wakes up on the hood
of the cop car
starts dancing basking in the adoration
of
all these riding people wearing clown
masks and draws the iconic joker smile
on his face with his own blood
all this happening while martha and
thomas wayne are walking out of the
excalibur theater
getting their batman origin story where
they're gunned down
by one of joker's admirers wearing a
clown mask we'll call him joe chill for
the purposes of this video just for
continuity's sake
he says you get what you deserve guns
them down and bruce wayne is standing
there over their dead bodies
very iconic batman moment a lot of
people wondered if this was going to
happen because we saw this shot in one
of the trailers
this is where it starts to throw you for
a bit of a loop when it comes to false
narration what's real what's fake
because the camera cuts to him inside
arkham asylum in this white cell being
interviewed by a psychiatrist
he starts laughing and when the woman
asks him what the joke is he calmly
replies you wouldn't get it as the
camera cuts back to bruce wayne
standing near his parents dead bodies in
the alleyway
he starts singing a song and then the
camera cuts again to him
walking down the hallway leaving
footprints of blood behind him on the
white floor
dancing his way out so because they're
always revealing things that weren't
happening the way they seemed that they
were happening a lot of this is
happening in joker's mind you're meant
to wonder
what's real in this final scene and
what's fake here's what was real
and here's what's fake remember the
joker is always imagining things in his
head like he imagines himself on murray
franklin's show when he's watching it at
the beginning of the film
i think everything is real he really did
kill murray franklin on live tv
he did surrender to the police but then
they took him straight to arkham
in the scene of him dancing on the cop
car hood is probably him just imagining
that
him inside the arkham cell that's real
but when he's walking away
leaving the footprints of blood that's
meant to imply that he killed that woman
the psychiatrist he was talking to and
he's in the process of escaping arkham
asylum
this kind of explains why there's such a
quick seeming time jump from him dancing
on the cop car hood to appearing in the
arkham cell
is that the dancing did not happen
that's all in his head but i do
think that joe chill killing thomas and
martha wayne giving batman his origin
story that was real
so i know there's going to be a ton of
theories after this weekend about them
doing a new batman film with joaquin
phoenix's joker
something completely different outside
the dc universe the reason why i'm not
so sure that that's going to happen
is because of the new matt reeves batman
trilogy warner brothers probably isn't
going to green light a couple different
versions of live action batman at the
same time
based on the age of young bruce wayne
here you could say that this is close to
being ben affleck's batman because ben
affleck is playing a late 40-something
batman during his batman movies
but a lot of people have wondered what
the joke he was referring to was
when he tells a psychiatrist you
wouldn't understand the joke i think
that was a reference to him finally
being lauded as a hero
at least in his mind despite all the
terrible things that he did the past few
weeks like i'm the hero and thomas wayne
is the villain
the added level of irony that thomas
wayne was partially responsible for his
own death because he called all these
deranged people
clowns that's why they were wearing
clown masks to begin with
then the meta aspect of both the joker
and thomas wayne
inevitably creating their own worst
villain so for thomas wayne he was
creating that joe chill
person wearing the clown mask that wound
up killing him but the more meta aspect
is
the joker was inadvertently indirectly
creating the batman by doing all this
too
so that's why he's saying that the
psychiatrist would not understand it
because it's such a complex
but beautiful meta joke joaquin phoenix
was actually asked in an interview
recently what his character would do if
he were suddenly confronted with someone
dressed up like a bat flying around
gotham fighting crime
and his answer was that his character
the joker would be incredibly happy at
the site he would laugh
genuinely ironically happy but delighted
by how his nihilistic view of the world
was seemingly confirmed by this
crazy person dressing up like a bat or
someone that he thought was just as
crazy as him
that gets into more killing joke easter
eggs you're one bad day away from being
me the joker trying to tell batman that
they're the exact same person
i've demonstrated there's no difference
between me and everyone else
all it takes is one bad day
a lot of you are also asking about the
picture of joker's mother signed by
thomas wayne
with a really intimate message on it
making it seem like maybe she was
telling the truth about her relationship
with thomas wayne
is if maybe there's a small chance that
arthur could be thomas wayne's son
but i think that's mostly just to throw
you for a bit of a loop i do think that
she had mental problems i do think that
she imagined her relationship with
thomas wayne
and even if he was maybe kind of amorous
with her they probably never had a child
together arthur really
is adopted because can you imagine what
comic book fandom would do if they tried
to say that the joker was thomas wayne's
son
the only version of the joker that is
thomas wayne's son is the batman who
laughs and they have not done him in the
movies yet
so just remember that parts of those
final 15 minutes of the movie the ending
are fake and imagined in his head
some of them are real if there's any
other big questions that you have about
the ending of the movie though just let
me know in the comments below but this
does give you a point of origin for this
version of batman whatever you want him
to look like
todd phillips made it seem like they're
not planning on doing any sequels but
joaquin phoenix
might be lured back if the film makes
enough money they might find a way to
get him back in a couple years but i
think it's more likely that they would
just do other
dc black label films with other batman
villains like a really hardcore r-rated
film about the riddler that would be
amazing but the riddler is going to be a
character during matt reeves batman
films so if you have any other big
questions about plot points in the movie
or the ending just let me know in the
comments and i'll try to address that in
my other easter egg videos this weekend
congratulations carvo you're the
giveaway winner from my last big dc
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so i can get your details
everybody click here for my joker movie
review and click here for that brand new
flash
season 6 crisis on infinite earth
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody put on a happy face i'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you